breaking news followed by more breaking
news a new headline every second no
where is the media market more
competitive than in New York to survive
financially media companies have to
develop diverse strategies 51 year old
public relations expert Jim Joseph
writes a blog for the online newspaper
The Huffington Post while I might be
giving my point of view it's awesome to
get their point of view back again and
then I learned from and it gives me more
to write about so it becomes this cycle
of learning and talking and dialoguing
and applying that we never had before
because you would just put an article
out and it would stop and now it keeps
going and keeps living which is which is
amazing thousands of other bloggers also
write to The Huffington Post but they
can't live off their work
I'm not paid to write my articles I do
it as part of my work and as part of
being a thought leader in the industry
so I don't get paid to write the article
I don't get paid to come and I do it
because I enjoy it and I like it and I
like the interaction without the
internet even respected papers like the
New York Times wouldn't have a future
because its income is generated by
clicks on advertising links Gabriel
dance now works for the Guardian
newspaper but it was once his job to
retain as many New York Times readers as
possible using multimedia our ability to
tell stories has gone from simply just
print and photographs to Interactive's
to maps to different types of games to
video and and really to all of those
forms combined this is one of the
computer games dance invented for the
New York Times it addresses an issue
found in articles in the paper the
dangers of writing text messages while
driving one of the strengths is that it
really engages a reader games is
something in which they actively
participate in and as soon as you have
one of your readers actually engaging
with your content it becomes much more
easy to get them to care more about that
content several New York companies
specialize in developing computer games
for media outlets one of them is games
for change the most popular article in
The New York Times in 2013 wasn't an
article it was an interactive quiz so
increasingly you know you're having
people on these websites they want
something you know a little more
interactive I think it's a little more
interesting and games I mean I think are
seeing a bump in in popularity across
across all demographic and the companies
benefit too
demand is growing for games that deal
with socially relevant issues so this is
half the sky movement the game
it's a point-and-click adventure game on
Facebook about fighting the oppression
of women worldwide it's based on a
best-selling book of the same name that
was written by a New York Times
journalist gabrielle dance still
considers himself a journalist he knows
that the internet is setting new
standards of journalism journalists have
to inform entertain and carry on a
lively dialogue with readers as soon as
the more traditional journalists see
that were in fact complimenting their
journalism with something that they
couldn't do on their own it starts to
make them I feel get much more excited
and encouraged about collaboration and
the future of their storytelling because
they find they're just reaching a wider
audience the media market in New York
and elsewhere will remain highly
competitive publishers and other media
outlets have to constantly change in
order to survive
you